bonsoir jean king avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors tout d'abord les
félicitations à son sombre rigueur vous
retrouvez votre fauteuil de maire alors
sentez vous la pression écologiste sur
écologique sur vos épaules
je ne sais pas si une pression
écologique mais je croise une nécessité
en fait et dans la liste que j'ai
conduit on avait pris également des
engagements pour que la bible dont
lequel je viens d'être élu soit une
ville plus durable plus écologique
également héros doit renforcer la
transition écologique donc une nécessité
et j'ai proposé dix engagements moi je
ne suis pas parti avec l'étiquette
l'écologiste puisque j'ai conduit une
liste divers gauche je suis parti
socialiste et il y avait lors de ce
deuxième tour une nice également soutenu
par le par l'europe écologique les verts
mais dom au programme
j'avais cette nécessité d'ailleurs quand
j'étais maire j'avais mis en place
également deux agendas 21 en 2009
j'avais par exemple interdit des
pesticides sur les espaces publics
et puis un deuxième en 2014 on avait
effectivement pris des mesures pour
mieux protéger notre environnement pour
le mettre en valeur également pour par
exemple dans dans les énergies on est
mis en place une chaufferie bois par
exemple deux en l'espace de 7 8 ans donc
c'est une nécessité c'est pas une
pression je crois que ça ça correspond
effectivement aux défis de demain je
crois que nous ne recevrons thématique
eux il ya une aura des conséquences très
importantes pour nos territoires
il ya beaucoup d'habitants qu en
prennent conscience et effectivement on
le voit dans les grandes métropoles où
les habitants et qui sont absolument
attentifs à ces évolutions mais se sont
davantage mobilisés et ont porté à leur
tête effectivement des élus écologistes
joaquim pueyo qu'aujourd'hui les verts
sont en train de prendre une forme
d'abandon sur le parti socialiste est
sûre elle est fille en tout cas sur la
gauche vous ne voyez pas les choses
comme ça à la lumière de ces résultats
quand même avec des surprises dans les
grandes villes non mais bien sûr on voit
très bien que le mouvement écologiste
dans son sens large du terme prendre
l'ampleur parce que d'une part le coc
vie
accélérer certaines prises de conscience
également lorsque par exemple on
souhaite renforcer de circuits courts la
qualité d'alimentation mettre du bio
dans les cantines scolaires à 100% bien
effectivement il ya une prise de
conscience très forte et le parti dans
le porte bien évidemment puisqu'ils ont
déjà porté depuis plusieurs années je
crois que l'avenir c'est plutôt un
rassemblement au niveau écologique et
sociale je pense que le parti socialiste
a un rôle non négligeable à jouer
d'ailleurs non les socialistes bien sûr
nous avons déjà développé des politiques
pour protéger l'environnement pour
renforcer la transition énergétique
je me souviens des appels à projets qui
avaient été lancées par l'ancien
gouvernement elle voit en tant que
communauté urbaine d'alençon nous avons
répondu à des projets pour qu'on soigne
un territoire d'énergie positive par
exemple dont je pense que dans beaucoup
de mouvements politiques
il ya cette prise de conscience mais
livré comme historiquement ce sont les
verts qui vont porter ces problématiques
bien ils sont plutôt effectivement ils
sont portés actuellement par par cette
nécessité
alors le premier secrétaire de votre
parti à olivet forcée du prêt je suis ta
se ranger derrière le candidat qui
interne aura le blog social écologiste
quel que soit son nom et géopolitique en
verrine 22 et vous moi c'est la même
chose je crois que mon l'a vu d'ailleurs
dans des grandes villes où des candidats
ne vais pas lui forcément d'expérience
politique locale se sont révélés à
travers une campagne municipale et ont
gagné donc je pense que la
présidentielle va va apporter
effectivement peut-être des surprises
je ne sais pas qui sera candidat pour la
gauche
voilà le parti socialiste pour les
écologistes est ce qu'on peut se mettre
d'accord sur un candidat avec les mêmes
valeurs je crois je provoque une bonne
valeur avec un projet qui correspond
effectivement aux nécessités
d'aujourd'hui de demain
c'est probable voilà donc c'est
peut-être une possibilité scrutin
évidemment marqué on le sait par une
abstention record c'est inspectant
sincère pour vous il est sincère
la mesure des habitants qui sont
déplacés mais effectivement il ya plus
de 60 % d'abstentionnistes il faut
l'analyser
je pense que vous avez des jeunes qui
sont en difficulté qui ont des problèmes
d'insertion mais ils ne vont pas voter
vous avez des familles qui ont été eux
atteint par la grille à la par la crise
et qui ne croient plus aux politiques
également dont il ya une rupture entre
le politique une certaine population
je crois qu'il faut absolument qu'on
renforce dans nos pratiques pendant les
nomades nature la démocratie
participative
il faut davantage associer les habitants
aux décisions de combat prendre le
niveau d'une collectivité d'un
territoire ou d'un département ou d'une
région
on le voit bien qu actuellement dans les
démocraties occidentales
le taux de participation est de moins en
moins important et donc il faut qu'on
s'interroge sur la manière dont d'être
démocratie doit être plus vivant et
façon à ce que les habitants soit mieux
associé faudra faire de la prévention
faudra faire de la citoyenneté également
dans les écoles dans les collèges dans
les lycées mais c'est vrai que c'est un
grand souci c'est un c'est un défi que
doit relever geste chose espérer qu'on
pourra le relever ensemble
merci beaucoup a été ma fille au député
ps de l'orne élu maire d'alençon fière
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france